- I love this dress.
(crowd cheering)
- Thank you.
- [Kate] All you would think.
- Meet Oliver, meet Kate.
- Hi.
- Hello.
- Such a big fan.
- Oh,
- Thanks.
- Get that out the gate, right away.
- Do you have brothers and sisters?
Do you have any siblings?
- I don't, I'm an only child.
- [Kelly] Oh, your an only child?
- [Kate] Oh, wow, this is
amusing to us. Oh, sorry.
- [Kelly] No, were you, were you,
- So, no this way.
- We're gonna fight.
[Kelly] like wanting a sibling,
when you were younger?
- So my mom's one of nine,
- [Kate] Oh.
- and everyone has like three kids each,
so I have a ton of cousins.
- Okay.
- Huh.
- So all of the sibling energy
and then they leave and it's just very,
- And you're all alone.
( laughing)
Oh, that's hard.
- I don't know, I thought it was great.
(laughing)
- You know, well it's interesting.
I feel like I fall under
different categories
'cause I have siblings
and then I also didn't
really grow up with,
so I grew up alone a lot as well.
So it, it's nice, yeah.
- It's nice.
And it's also kind of hard socializing
'cause I'm so used to being on my own,
that it's like that introvert
where as soon as I'm tapped out,
I'm like done and I have to leave.
But,
- [Kate] Yeah.
- I feel like when you have a sibling
you don't really get a choice.
If you share a room or,
- Yeah, I tap out.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah, Tap out.
- I tap out.
- I think everyone taps.
(laughing)
So acting was huge in their family,
but is it huge in yours?
Anybody act in your family?
- No, accountants,
- [Kelly] Okay.
- and small business owners.
- What?
Okay, so were they just like, huh?
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Okay.
Because I love that you
actually, you gave up botany,
which I find interesting.
I love plants.
I'm obsessed.
- [Alicia] I mean,
- I love gardening
and you have gardeners.
- [Alicia] Yes, yes.
- Right?
- So my grandpa was a horticulturalist,
among many other things.
- So cool.
- My mom loves to garden and, and it's one
of her favorite things to do.
And so I grew up kind of around it.
And when I went to university, I was like
I'll study a science, botany.
Everyone was like, "Why?" And,
(laughing)
I was like,
- [Kelly] Why not?
- "Well, I was just interested in it."
And I figured maybe the path
would lead me to a career,
which it did.
I worked for the Smithsonian
in the Panama Canal for like,
- Fine.
- [Kate] Oh, wow.
- A year.
- [Kelly] Wow.
That's so random.
- It is so random.
- [Kelly] Yeah, well congrats
on the second season of,
"Raising Dion" because my,
(crowd cheering)
I have to tell you,
I was telling them
while I was playing my, you will never,
my seven year old was like,
"Mom, you have to watch the show with me."
She's never done that.
And it was, "Raising Dion."
- Ahh.
- [Kelly] Like, I was like,
"Okay, we'll watch a show together
like this, that's not animated."
Thank you.
- Your welcome.
- [Kelly] Um, and, and it's great.
I love it, I love it.
Did you, did you love the script,
like right off the bat
whenever you got it?
- Oh, absolutely.
And when I read it, I
talked with the show runner,
and we were just really
connecting on some of the themes.
And then I called my mom
and I started telling her
that I'm reading for a show
playing a single mom.
And my mom's a single mother, so,
- Oh.
- We just immediately started talking
about stories of my childhood
and ways that she was
connecting with the material,
which made me feel like,
if I do the show
it's a way for my mom and I to bond.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Which it ended up being that way.
- And you're also representing like a
a group of women and
men, single dads as well.
That, that's hard.
- It is hard.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Even playing a fake one on TV.
(laughing)
- [Kelly] No, but it's a hard role.
- Yeah,
- So, that's kind of awesome
that you have like that just,
firsthand knowledge at home.
That's awesome.
- Yeah, yeah, it was incredible.
And our cast is very family oriented
and so everyone was chiming in
with how they were raised.
And it was just such a
fun place to make a show
because it did feel like a family.
- You have so many people
there for your podcast.
I'm thinking,
- I'm, yeah I know.
I'm so I'm curious though,
what made you want to get into acting?
- [Alicia] Okay, so I was five
and I, Publix is like a grocery store,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- In Florida.
And someone approached my mom being like,
"Oh you should put your child
in kid modeling," or whatever.
And so I did that for like five minutes.
Until my mom realized how you
have to kind of schlep around
all over town taking
your child to auditions.
She's like, "We're not doing that."
- Yeah.
- So,
- 'Cause she is a single mom.
- [Alicia] She is a single mom.
She's not gonna take time off of work
and not get paid for an audition.
- Yeah.
- She was just like,
"This is not for us."
So fast, forward years later,
and one of my coworkers was
trying to become an actor
and I was like, oh it's kind of hitting
that spot of creativity
where I wanted to tell stories.
So he actually helped me.
- [Kate] Oh, cool.
- Get into it in San Francisco.
So it's very,
- Random happenstance.
- And now your coworkers
like, "Damn it, she made it.
And I'm still here."
(laughing)
- I'm sorry. (laughing)